Speaker 1: We start today with a stunning
speech from President Joe Biden last night
defending democracy.
Joe Biden had to give a speech saying democracy
is a good thing and we should work to keep
it and we should fight against the people
that want to destroy it and to want to tear
it down.
Imagine that.
Imagine a situation in 2022, almost 2023 United
States, where we have a movement in the country
so unhinged, but also so powerful, not overwhelmingly
powerful.
They didn't succeed in 2020, but they didn't
come that far.
Let's be honest.
A movement powerful enough in its extremism
afox news nd unhinged nature that the current
president on the proverbial eve, not the literal
eve, but the proverbial eve of the 2022 midterms,
a president who won, even though they say
he lost, by the way, had to come out and defend
democracy and argue we shouldn't become violent
to overthrow democracy.
That's a bad thing.
It is a disgusting reality that we have to
face, that this is where we are in almost
2023.
Let's start with Joe Biden very clearly talking
about what is the origin of this problem.
Speaker 2: You know, American democracy under
attack because the defeated former president
of the United States refused to accept the
results of the 2020 election.
He refuses to accept the will of the people.
He refuses to accept the fact that he lost.
He has abused his power and put the loyalty
to himself before loyalty to the Constitution.
And he's made a big lie.
An article of faith in the major Republican
Party.
Indeed, the minority of that party.
The great irony.
Speaker 1: About half of the party, let's
be fair.
Speaker 2: About the 2020 election is that
it's the most attacked election in our history.
And yet and yet there's no election in our
history that we can be more certain of its
results.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we can be completely sure
that Joe Biden genuinely won.
And Joe Biden not only putting the blame and
the responsibility squarely on Trump and MAGA,
but also pointing out that this is an extremely
consequential midterm election, which is something
I've been saying at this point for a year
or longer.
Speaker 2: I know there's a lot at stake in
these midterm elections from our economy,
the safety of our streets to our personal
freedoms, the future of health care, Social
Security, Medicare, it's all important.
But we'll have our differences.
We have our difference of opinion.
That's what supposed to be.
But there's something else at stake, right?
Democracy itself.
I'm not the only one who sees it.
Recent polls have shown that overwhelming
majority of Americans believe our democracy
is at risk, that our democracy is under threat.
They to see that democracy is on the ballot
this year.
Speaker 1: These are the types of speeches
that often opposition leaders give.
In dictatorships.
Okay.
It is out of this world, cuckoo, that this
is the type of speech that Joe Biden finds
himself giving.
And he that we're going to get to how the
right wing was triggered by this speech.
He made clear, even when it comes to January
6th, that was not the end of the assault on
democracy.
And as you know, if you've been following
this show, there are dozens, if not more Republicans
running right now on the ballot who deny the
results of the election.
Speaker 2: Look, even as I speak here tonight,
27 million people have already cast their
ballot in the midterm elections.
Millions more will cast their ballots in the
final days leading up to November the ninth.
Eighth, excuse me.
And for the first time, this is the first
time since the national election in 2020.
Once again, we're seeing record turnout all
over the country, and that's good.
We want Americans to vote.
We want every American's voice to be heard.
Now we have to move the process forward.
We know that more and more ballots are cast
in early voting or by mail in America.
And we know that many states don't start counting
those ballots.
So after the polls close in November.
That means in some cases, we won't know the
winner of the election for a few days until
a few days after the election.
It takes time to count all legitimate ballots
in a legal and orderly manner.
It's always been important for citizens in
the democracy to be informed and engaged.
Now it's important for citizens to be patient
as well.
That's how it's supposed to work.
This is also the first election since the
events of January 6th, when the armed, angry
mob stormed the U.S. Capitol.
I wish I wish I could say the assault on a
democracy ended that day.
It did.
But I cannot.
As I stand here today.
There candidates running for every level of
office in America for governor, Congress,
attorney general, secretary of state, who
won't commit they will not commit to accepting
the results of the election that they're running
in.
Speaker 1: In fact, they're saying, if I lose,
it's rigged.
If I win, it's fair.
Joe Biden also addressing the rise in the
number of people who are saying violence to
achieve your political goals is okay.
Speaker 2: We have to be honest with ourselves,
though.
We have to face this problem.
We can't turn away from it.
We can't pretend it's just going to solve
itself.
There's an alarming rise in the number of
our people in this country condoning political
violence.
Yeah.
Or simply remaining silence.
Because silence is complicity to disturbing
rise of voter intimidation, the pernicious
tendency to excuse political violence, or
at least at least trying to explain it away.
We can't allow this sentiment to grow.
We must confront it head on now.
It has to stop now.
I believe the voices excuse me are calling
for violence and intimidation are distinct
minority in America.
Speaker 1: I do not know.
Well, a minority in America.
Let's hope so.
A minority in the Republican Party.
I'm not quite sure.
And unfortunately, many of the people minimizing
the January six Trump riots are not necessarily
welcoming, but certainly inspiring.
The perceived legitimacy of political violence
in the minds of their supporters.
Many of them could win and some of them probably
will.
President Biden going on to connect Trump's
big lie on the attack on Paul Pelosi.
And they are connected.
Speaker 2: And all this happened after the
assault.
And it just I fight so hard to even say.
It's hard to even say after the assailant
entered the home asking, where's Nancy?
Where's Nancy?
Those are the very same words used by the
mob when they stormed the United States Capitol
on January six.
Literally when they broke windows, kicked
in the doors, brutally attacked law enforcement,
roamed the corridors hunting for officials
and erected gallows to hang the former Vice
President Mike Pence.
It was an enraged mob that had been whipped
up into a frenzy by a president repeating
over and over again the big lie that the election
of 2020 had been stolen.
Speaker 1: It is indeed the exact same line
that you follow through those phenomena.
Joe Biden warning ahead of time, as I mentioned
before, that it will take some time to count
all of the legitimate ballots and that that's
okay.
And then eventually Biden closing by saying
the following year.
Speaker 2: We're often not faced with questions
of whether the vote we cast will preserve
democracy or put us at risk.
But this year, we are.
This year, I hope you'll make the future of
our democracy an important part of your decision
to vote and how you vote.
I hope you'll ask a simple question of each
candidate you might vote for.
Will that person accept the legitimate will
of the American people and people voting in
his district or her district?
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's shocking that that's
the top line question we have to ask.
There are there you've got the candidates
who have their policy and they will accept
the results of the election.
And then you've got the candidates that will
not.
That's a major dividing line.
Who respects the will of the voter here?
Speaker 2: Will that person accept the outcome
of the election, win or lose?
The answer to that question is vital, and
in my opinion, it should be decisive.
And the answer to that question hangs on the
future of the country we love so much and
the fate of the democracy that has made so
much possible for us.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
A good speech.
A really dystopian reality in which such a
speech is necessary and logical.
So Joe Biden did a few important things here
other than defend the idea that we thought
we had a democracy.
We should probably work to try to keep that.
He issued a sort of warning about Republicans
planning to undermine the vote on Tuesday.
And we're going to have clips later on and
on tomorrow's show of ways in which they are
already doing this and other examples.
So Republicans are already doing that.
They're making it clear they're telegraphing
they're going to be doing that on Tuesday.
Joe Biden sort of trying to sound the alarm
in advance the way we were doing and many
in progressive media were doing in advance
of the 2020 election.
It was very clear what Trump was going to
do.
And at two something in the morning on election
night, 2020, he did.
He came out and said, Oh, I won.
Even though he had not won.
And then the other thing is he's setting expectations
about it'll take a few days in some of these
elections to know the results, particularly
because in some of these places they don't
actually start counting anything until the
polls close.
There will be a hold, but Pennsylvania is
an example.
Actually, I don't remember if Pennsylvania
doesn't start until the polls close, but they
stop at a particular time.
A whole bunch of accumulated mail in and early
ballots will be there, but they will not start
to be counted until polls close, in many cases
at 8 p.m. local time.
So an important speech.
Very sad that he had to make it.
Let's now look at the reactions from the right